c'est une nouvelle étape dans le bras de
fer engagé entre les pushis du Niger et
Paris l'ultimatum exigeant le départ des
troupes françaises du pays vient expirer
ce dimanche 3 septembre il y a
exactement un mois quelques jours à
peine après que le général Abdourahmane
tiani a renversé le président nigérien
mohamed Bazoum la nouvelle jante
militaire dénonçait ses accords
militaires avec la France qui compte
1500 soldats au Niger déployés dans le
cadre de la lutte antidualiste dans le
Sahel la France ne se laissera pas
impressionner assuré pourtant vendredi
1er septembre le ministre des Armées
Sébastien Lecornu Paris rejette en effet
la légitimité du nouveau pouvoir il
n'est pas question de se plier à cette
situation de fait alors que si un
président a une légitimité démocratique
claire c'est bien mohamed Bazoum
pourtant l'avenir des forces françaises
dans le pays est plus incertain que
jamais des milliers de manifestants se
sont rassemblés ce samedi 2 septembre
proximité de la base militaire française
située dans la périphérie de la capitale
Niamey vive le Niger Abala France dans
la foule les mêmes slogans et les mêmes
drapeaux russes et nigériens que lors
des manifestations précédentes ce
jour-là la foule s'était également
rassemblée épicentre des manifestations
depuis le Pusch du 26 juillet pour
l'agence au pouvoir c'est une victoire
de plus après un mois de bras de fer
avec la France la mobilisation populaire
était au plus haut selon les
observateurs locaux la stratégie adoptée
par le Conseil national pour la
sauvegarde de la patrie donc se donne
les militaires ayant pris le pouvoir
mais pourtant pas nouvelle déjà éprouvé
au Mali au Burkina Faso ou les forces
françaises ont été forcées de plier
bagages en 2021 et 2022 respectivement
le discours anti-colonial des autorités
puchistes profitent d'un ressentiment
ancien et des aspirations souverainistes
des populations locales il y a un grand
besoin idéologique de retour à une autre
identité qui n'implique pas la France
pour une grande partie de la population
surtout au sein de la jeunesse fin août
le colonel pucciste ibro Amadou
présentait l'axe principal de la
nouvelle politique nigérienne le combat
ne s'arrêtera que le jour où il n'y aura
plus aucun militaire français au Niger
car dès les premières heures du coup
d'État la France a maintenu une position
ferme elle a appuyé les sanctions
économiques et financières imposées au
Niger par la Cedeao la Communauté
économique des États d'Afrique de
l'Ouest et n'a pas caché son soutien
pour une éventuelle intervention
militaire destinée à rétablir l'ordre
constitutionnel dans le pays face à cela
le CNSP a fustigé le premier septembre
l'ancienne puissance coloniale et les
incessants effort d'Emmanuel Macron en
faveur d'une invasion du Niger qui
viserait à perpétuer une entreprise
néocolonialiste sur le peuple nigérien
paradoxalement la grande fermeté de la
position française vis-à-vis des
puccistes à alimenter le sentiment
anti-français il était d'autant plus
facile pour les puccistes de critiquer
l'ingérence française partenaire d'hier
l'ancienne puissance coloniale française
est jugée responsable d'avoir maintenu
en vie un ancien régime corrompu et
impotant pour beaucoup de Nigériens le
contraste entre la richesse de leur
sous-sol et la pauvreté de leur pays ne
s'explique que par la voracité des
entreprises tricolores la permanence de
la violence des groupes armés malgré les
efforts des soldats français alimentent
également les ressentiments si les
Français ne sont pas capables de se
débarrasser de quelques djihadistes
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas là pour ça
c'est qu'ils sont au Niger pour d'autres
intérêts après avoir suspendu les médias
RFI et France 24 considérés comme la
voix de la France la jungle a exigé le
25 août dernier le départ de
l'ambassadeur français mais si elle est
capable de rallier l'opinion nigérienne
à Paris cette rhétorique anti-française
ne convainc pas les puccistes n'ont pas
de cap politique il cache le vide de
leur programme derrière une diatrie
populiste contre la France afin de
rallier facilement la population